comme ça au moins on gagne du temps je
me suis posé la question
cet après midi j'étais en réunion avec
moi même toute l'équipe de ses mythes et
la présidence du groupe de la production
et on s'est posé la question suivante
que fait sûr et bien entendu j'ai pensé
à une seule et unique personne
elle publie cos au mexique a lancé et on
s'est posé la question qu'est ce qu'on
fait est ce qu'on diffuse l'intervention
de emmanuel macron tout ça et je me suis
dit oui mais non oui mais non oui mais
non pourquoi
ravi qu'on propose autre chose parce que
tu as on va savoir ce qui va lire un oui
à un moment on n'est pas dans la pampa
non mais c'est vrai une alerte sur le
smartphone une multiplication agricole
sa chez les coiffeurs sont ouverts on le
saura non mais c'est vrai voilà si on
peut appeler demain diminutif diminutif
bonjour mme nadine à laquelle on le
saura a donc je me suis dit autant faire
une autre proposition
contre-programmation et je me suis dit
qu'est ce qu'on peut proposer trois ans
d'efforts ailleurs tard car on connaît
nos médias et en arca voilà j'ai réussi
mon conseil de défense
lionel stan bac à combes et loïc jamin
assez haut
c'est la grosse équipe là est bien
entendu mon nourdine d'amour qui est
dans mon oreille
qu'ils soient là et on a pris la
décision de ne rien faire nathan
[Applaudissements]
c'est là en bas de friser les moustaches
durera 35
si on faisait un test on faisait que des
trucs e d'arca tu vois voilà un peu de
médias de l'adar cas ça rigole tout ça
combien ont fait d'audience et là je me
suis dit les règles qui vont me regarder
entre 20h10 d'accord makrout va parler
elle annuel makrouds pas parler et le
moment où tu as plus parler c'est
vraiment les gars s'en fout vraiment un
gros coup droit
je veux voir bordel de merde
ce soir ce que je vais voir demain les
fidèles je pourrais vous dire les vrais
fils est là c'est pas la fin de ma cela
c'est la fan de lasser les gars c'est
comme moi à moi je vous avais que vous
lâchera jamais moi par exemple voilà si
vous faites une émission bah moi je vous
laisse pas je regarde pas macron je
regarde le public tac tac il faut qu ils
font un frisbee bosch leurs gardes parce
que manuel ma comptes qui va dire on le
sait on si tu veux dire on le sait déjà